all right audience now a lot of breaking
news tonight Florida congressman Ron de
Santos by the way I'm hoping will be the
next governor of the great the great
state of Florida the Sunshine State
full disclosure for you dopes over at
MSNBC and Fox News contributor Sarah
Carter Sarah let's start with you
so I was speaking with you last night
and we were speaking to other people and
we were both working on sources and then
again this morning at 7 o'clock there
was supposed to be released documents
from the DOJ early in the morning and
then they pulled them back what happened
absolutely I mean the DOJ failed to
mention that when they issued a press
release last night Sean after midnight
stating that they would turn over
documents next week or at least allow
Congress to review documents next week
either Monday or Tuesday and ask more
questions about the information that
they had requested on April 24th which
was a specific documentation by the
House Intelligence Committee that would
basically shed light on the entire
Russia investigation it's these
documents that the DOJ and the FBI are
refusing to turn over to lawmakers and
this is significant
they had battled with them on May 24th
remember that meeting that they had
where the DOJ and FBI were supposed to
share documents with Nunez and
representative trey Gowdy and others and
they did not they in fact told them that
they would not share those documents
with investigators on their committee so
this has been a back-and-forth battle
they refused to turn them over this
morning instead issuing a press release
late last night that nobody was aware of
except for the reporters but the
congressional members were left in the
dark they headed to Capitol Hill they
were waiting for the documents and once
again they weren't there all right I got
some breaking news if I can throw this
at you congressman this is in the new
york times federal law enforcement the
headline is Justice Department seizes
Times reporters email and phone records
in leak investigation federal law
enforcement officials secretly seizing a
year's worth the New York Times
reporters phone and email records this
year in an investigation of classified
information
Leakes excuse me don't we have a first
amendment he hiked by the way I never
thought it would be defending the New
York Times they do suck but wait a
minute they don't have a right to this
reporters notes this reporters records
we do it they aren't they allowed to
protect their sources do we have freedom
of press this is this sounds scary to me
what's your reaction well it's also
against the backdrop Shawn nobody has
been prosecuted who's actually done
leaking since this administration took
over I mean remember Michael Flynn that
intercept was a FISA intercept that was
leaked gratuitously by somebody probably
an Obama hold over there have been a
cascade of leaks and nobody has been
held accountable for any of those things
so I need more information about what
exactly is happening here I know that
there's a former staffer on the Senate
Intelligence Committee that is probably
going to be indicted I'm not sure if it
was working for a Democrat or a
Republican although I have my guess but
at the end of the day you've had a
series of leaks and no accountability up
to this point I will tell you news media
and they write this in The Times piece
consider the idea of mining a journalist
records for sources a massive intrusion
into the First Amendment Sarah Carter
could we work sources last night and
it's none of their business who we
talked to who you talk to who I talk to
you tomorrow doesn't have a right to
this information absolutely absolutely I
mean I think that when we look at
overall you know what's been happening
here look James clapper
has now been outed pretty much as
someone who the the Congress believes
had leaked information to CNN we know
that the president's conversations
private conversations were leaked to the
media but that does not give the right
for the DOJ to start mining reporters
telephone numbers mining reporters
information to try to find out who was
the leaker I mean I think they pretty
much know where the leaks are coming
from give polygraphs I mean if they're
leaking highly classified usually look
at their own office that's right like
Mike Flynn maybe give some polygraphs
and find out who
was leaking inside the DOJ or inside the
FBI or inside the administration as to
these highly classified leaks this is
huge news here because and I am just put
it we're just putting this together New
York Times even their own leadership is
commenting on this maybe the New York
Times congressman Sanders maybe they'll
now realize people like Sean Hannity may
have been right in Sarah Carter and so
money of us Greg Jarrett
because we have pointed out FISA abuses
lying to FISA Court judges no missions
by lying to FISA Court judges Hillary
Clinton's crimes the dual justice system
in this country one for Christian
saucier one for Hillary fixing
investigations and everything else
associated with this and and that has
been our point the entire time
congressman how do we get to the bottom
of this now and they fight tooth and
nail to provide the American people the
truth about activities mean Rosenstein
as Sarah said even just last night
they're refusing to turn over these
documents people are saying that their
briefing certain members of Congress
saying oh this is exactly what we'd want
the FBI to do well if that's the case
then why don't you show the American
people the documents show Congress so we
can see how good a job you did the fact
that they're not willing to do that that
tells me that there were problems from
the very beginning of this so-called
collusion investigation they won't show
us the Papadopoulos stuff they won't
show us the information about halper and
you got to ask yourself why won't they
come back for tonight Sarah Carter
absolutely what was the scope of all of
this I think what we're seeing Sean and
I've said this over and over again is
just one small portion of massive abuse
and the American people deserve the
truth because our country relies on the
foundation that we built ourselves upon
and it's not meant for spying it's not
meant for weaponizing the intelligence
community something has to be done here
and Congress has to fight even harder to
get them to get those answers